Quick announcement up top—I’m now
partnered with Dragon Shield! Follow
my affiliate link in the description to get
a discount on your online sleeve purchases,
and keep an eye out in the coming weeks
for an awesome custom sleeve design that
me and my artist friend are cooking
up at the moment. Now, onto the video.
Lorwyn Eclipsed is here, and my patrons
have decreed that I will be reviewing the
-1/-1 counter precon. Which is great, because
Blight Curse has been a lot of fun to dig into,
and is pretty phenomenal as far as preconstructed
commander decks go in my opinion. Not because it’s
a perfect deck, and we can work on that part
in a bit, but for a lot of other reasons we’ll
be getting into. As usual, I’m going to start by
talking about what this deck is trying to do, then
I’ll be discussing what I like about it, and I’ll
finish up with some ways it could be improved.
To start with, let’s talk about this deck’s
main commander, Auntie Ool. She is a 4 mana
4/4 with Ward: Blight 2, and “Whenever one
or more -1 counters are put on a creature,
draw a card if you control that creature. If you
don’t control it, its controller loses 1 life.”
The first thing I notice about this is a lack of
limiting phrases in this text box—no “one or more
creatures”, and no once per turn. What this means
is that this has the potential to be a pretty
explosive value generator, easily drawing 5 or
more cards per turn with the right setup present.
On a 4 mana 4/4 commander with a protective
ability on it, that’s pretty good. The downside
here is the specificity—in total there are an okay
number of cards that put -1 counters on creatures,
but it’s not a particularly generous pool to
work with when you consider that these cards
function in a wide variety of different ways. Some
put -1 counters on all creatures, rewarding wide
boards with massive card advantage, whereas others
gain -1 counters over time, rewarding a slower,
grindier playstyle. Plenty of others are one time
use, and a lot of cards that use -1 counters are
primarily intended to put counters on opposing
creatures and are balanced with this in mind.
Do you place these on your own creatures instead
for a bit of card advantage? All this to say,
Auntie Ool is a powerful commander
within her own synergy sphere,
and the challenge in building her
is going to be navigating a limited
card pool to create a deck that plays to her
strengths without ending up too disjointed.
Looking at this deck’s cards that place -1
counters, there are 9 cards that specifically
place -1 counters on your creatures, another
9 that place -1 counters on any creature,
2 cards that place counters on each opposing
creature, and 4 cards that place counters on
all creatures. This array of different -1 counter
cards is accompanied by a number of payoff cards,
which likewise operate in a variety of
different ways. 8 of these trigger when
creatures with -1 counters on them die,
with most of these either providing card
advantage or reanimating the creatures under your
control. Another 4 cards plus the commander reward
the act of placing counters itself, and the
synergies get much more granular from here,
including amplifier cards like Evolution
Sage, cards that modify the effect of
-1 counters like Kulrath Knight, and weird
roundabout synergies like Tree of Perdition.
Some of the setup and payoff combinations here
are quite good, especially the ones involving
cards that place -1 counters onto all creatures,
and I expect that piecing together one of these
zingy pairings is a big way this deck will try
to get ahead. Naturally, this deck has a lot
of tools to slow opposing creature-based
gameplans given its focus on -1 counters,
and these creature-shrinking options are joined
by 5 cards that deal with artifacts, enchantments,
or both. Rounding out the 99 of this deck
are moderate counts of both draw and ramp,
much of which involves -1/-1 counters in some way.
Through some powerful synergies, I expect this
deck will try to get ahead in explosive fashion,
slow opposing gameplans with interaction, and then
gradually wear down opponents with a mixture
of creature attacks and incremental damage.
So, to start with what I like about this deck,
this strikes me as quite a “Johnny” sort of
precon. Because the deck was drawing from a
limited card pool, the -1 counter synergies
take a variety of different shapes, and the
setups and payoffs within this deck piece
together in some really cool, and sometimes really
powerful, ways. Just thinking about Auntie Ool,
the cards that place -1 counters on all creatures
end up being a Shamanic Revelation for you and a
Rakdos Charm for your opponents, both effects
that can be very impactful depending on the
state of the game. Any proliferate effects
can amplify the effect of previous counters,
creating further value and damage at a brisk
pace. These plays can also be doubled down on
with an additional payoff card like Hapatra or
Flourishing Defenses, which can put you in the
driving seat of a game fast. The deck also has
two different cards that reanimate creatures
that die with -1 counters on them, both at three
mana, and this means that it’s possible to perform
some powerful creature-stealing maneuvers
pretty early in the game. All this to say,
this deck can do some powerful things, and the
way it operates seems like it’d make for an
exciting play experience for any players who are
especially interested in the way cards synergize.
Just a minute ago I talked about the two cards
that reanimate opposing creatures that die with
-1/-1 counters on them, and one of these two is
actually the alternate commander for this deck,
The Reaper King No More. And, that’s
another thing I like about this deck:
it actually feels like it has an alternate
commander. The power level of the card is nice,
being basically a sidegrade of Necroskitter that
trades some raw power for a bit more utility,
and the deck does have a fair amount of cards that
place -1 counters on opposing creatures in it. So,
this deck has a better relationship with its
alt commander than most precons in the sense
that if you really like this card, you can
run it as the commander and probably have
an okay time with it. If you were doing that
long-term you’d want to tweak the deck a bit,
since Auntie Ool is pretty pivotal to the deck’s
card economy, but The Reaper is already much
closer to feeling good as a commander in
this deck than most alternate commanders,
and I’ll talk a bit later about some
possible ways to adapt this deck to him.
As usual, I playtested the deck 20 times and
kept track of how the first 5 turns went in
an excel doc. Overall, it felt decent—there
weren’t many games where the deck was really
popping off super early like I had when I was
testing the Worldshaper precon last year, but
most games the deck was doing some decent stuff
and setting up for cool plays later in the game.
One cool thing is how varied the deck felt—there
are so many different ways the different synergy
elements can be pieced together, whether that be
making a value engine, making a removal engine,
having a single explosive turn, putting together
a wide board, and so on. The commander also really
helps with making the deck feel good, for two
reasons. For one, she offers an easy default
-1 counter payoff, reducing the strain on
the deck to find other payoffs. Secondly,
the fact that she’s a powerful draw engine allows
somebody piloting the deck to see more of it,
which is super useful for a deck whose cards
are highly varied in how they work and what
they accomplish. As a final note about what I
like here, the manabase is fine enough for what
this deck is doing. Upgrade it if you like,
but I’ll be leaving it alone in my tweaks.
Getting into what I dislike about playing this
deck, the big thing is dead cards. I had several
playtests where I kept accumulating cards in
hand that were entirely useless in my current
gamestate. A lot of these are cards that are
just a bit more specific in their play pattern
or in the way they synergize with other cards,
being a little niche or hard to fully utilize
with the current tools. There is one frequently
dead card we should get out of the way first,
though—Liliana, Death Wielder is an intro deck
planeswalker from Amonkhet, and it is truly
godawful. It’d be barely playable at 4 mana, and
in reality it’s 7 mana, because it’s an intro deck
planeswalker. I guess this was added to this deck
to be an educational first cut for new players,
a la Temple of the False God, but I don’t like
that an iconic planeswalker like Liliana is
reduced to serving that role here. Anyway,
that’s our first cut, and it should be a cut
basically regardless of what you want to do with
this deck. Another thing I dislike about this
deck’s current form is its creature count—this
feels like a deck that wants to be running 35-40
creatures based on the number of cards that care
about creatures, but instead it’s running 27.
This adds to the awkwardness, when the deck
keeps drawing into enchantments and sorceries
and struggles to get much use out of something
like Soul Snuffers or Grave Venerations that
really wants more creatures floating around in
the ecosystem. So, these are the main things I
want to be focused on in my upgrade: reducing
dead draws, and upping the creature count.
Before I get into my other 9 cuts, though, I want
to talk about alternative build paths, because
that’s another reason I really like this precon
as a product. There are a lot of little elements
here that could easily spark some inspiration and
be expanded outward. A few proliferate cards help
the deck amplify its -1 counters, and one way
to modify this deck could be to lean harder
into that mechanic and add other cards that
can utilize it such as Astral Cornucopia and
Twitching Doll. There may not be a massive pool
of -1 counter cards in the game, but there sure
are a lot of other counter-using cards around that
can utilize some of the same payoffs and support.
Another synergy area this deck gives a taste of is
graveyard synergies—there are several cards that
use graveyards, as well as Archfiend of Ifnir that
cares about discarding. These aren’t very well
supported now, but you could introduce some more
looting effects into the deck to help with these,
and this extra filtering would also likely help
the deck in general in the pursuit of assembling
engines. Finally, you could also adapt the
deck to work better with The Reaper in the
command zone. There are several great cards that
put -1 counters on opposing creatures that you
could add if you don’t mind paying a bit, such as
Persistent Constrictor and Spitting Dilophosaurus,
and these paired with a bit more draw would likely
make for a very different, but still functional,
playstyle. This would also likely work
well paired with a more graveyard-heavy
or proliferate-heavy approach as well—you can
do a bit of mixing and matching among these.
For my upgrade, I’m choosing to go for a
more streamlined approach that eliminates
some potential deadweight and shores up some weak
spots, while increasing the creature count and
improving the tools for incremental -1 counters.
Let’s start with cuts. Archfiend of Ifnir is
getting cut because this deck has 5 other cards
that discard, and 3 of those are cycling lands.
This was one of my first observations after
plugging this deck into Archidekt—I saw an
Archfiend of Ifnir, I dropped “fo:discard”
into the search box, and boom, that’s an
easy cut unless you’re feeling highly motivated
to get more self-discard into this bad boy. I’m
also cutting Puca’s Covenant and Persist due
to this deck’s lack of graveyard-enabling.
The former requires your creatures dying and
stuff in your graveyard to be gotten back,
which is too niche a set of requirements for
the current form of this deck. Persist will
be useful a bit more often, but its ceiling is
also much lower, so it doesn’t excite me either.
I am keeping the rest of the graveyard synergies
around, though, as they have a lot more utility
than these two. Speaking of persist, Puppeteer
Clique—this card looks like it synergizes with
the deck, but in practice you’ll probably be
struggling not to turn off its keyword more
often than you’ll be enjoying that extra Auntie
Ool trigger. I’m also cutting Grim Poppet—this
one is a bit painful as it’s a funky card with
some neat possibilities here, but 7 is such a
large amount of mana to pay for something
with no guarantee of doing much. From here,
the final four cuts are noncreature filler, which
will be getting replaced with creatures and other
options better suited to this deck. Harmonize
and Hoarder’s Greed are getting cut for alternate
draw, Commander’s Sphere for an alternate mana
rock, and Cathartic Pyre for a better removal
spell. I will say, the fact that I am spending 4
of my 10 swaps targeting perfectly passable filler
speaks well to this deck’s card quality—there’s
just not many truly objectionable cards here.
Now for the additions. I’m starting here
with four low cost creatures with blight
abilities from the Lorwyn: Eclipsed main
set: Dawnhand Dissident, Gristle Glutton,
Scuzzback Scrounger, and Shadow Urchin. Adding
these lowers our curve, ups our creature count,
makes it easier to trigger the commander
on-demand, and as an added bonus 3 of the 4
have fun, alliterative names. You could also add
the haste one if you wanted to, but I don’t see
this deck wanting haste on a single creature all
that often. As replacement creature-based draw,
I’m adding Generous Patron, which can potentially
net quite a solid amount of cards. To replace
the mana rock and creature removal we cut, I’m
adding Staff of Compleation and Grim Affliction,
both of which can also proliferate. From here, I’m
also a bit concerned about this deck’s ability to
maintain a healthy life total—it’s on the grindier
side, there was already some big lifepay in the
deck, and we just added some more big life
pay in the form of Staff of Completion. So,
the remaining additions will also perform a
stabilizing role here. Obelisk Spider is great
as a source of incremental damage, pairing
with the commander to pepper down opponents
at a steady pace and gaining a bit of life in the
process. Pest Infestation boosts the deck’s count
of artifact and enchantment destruction,
while also gaining life and cementing the
advantages this deck gains from having a wide
board. Finally, Elegy Acolyte gives a nice
lifelinking body in addition to some draw, further
smoothing this deck out in multiple regards. —
So this is our finished version of the deck, with
significantly expanded connective tissue and a
creature count of 32, up from 27. I will say that
in my tweaks here, I was very conservative with my
cuts to cards that pressure opposing life totals.
I don’t know that Grave Titan, Lasting Tarfire,
Tree of Perdition, or Flourishing Defenses
belong here long term, but this is definitely
one of the grindier precons I’ve seen, and I
didn’t want to handicap its ability to win by
cutting perfectly passable pressure options
just because they could be a bit better.
I will also reiterate that money will go further
in upgrading this deck than it would for a lot of
precons. Because the card pool is so narrow,
there are great cards that use -1 counters
that don’t really have budget replacements, and
you’d probably want to eventually snag those if
you’re trying to upgrade this deck to a fully
functional bracket 3 form. I will also say,
that narrow card pool itself is part of why I like
this precon so much. It’d be easy for this to end
up being a precon that feels a bit one-trick-pony
and really constrained in how you could go about
improving it, but instead the opposite is true.
This deck has a reasonable alternative commander,
multiple possible modification paths presenting
themselves, and it contains fewer obvious cuts
than any other precon I’ve reviewed. Part of that
comes down to the cards that are in the deck,
but another big part comes down to the design of
the commander. Auntie Ool is a great enabler for
-1 counters that encourages diving deep into
the mechanic and playing around with synergy,
and that’s cool to see. The overall package
works well, and if you’re trying to get
somebody into commander who is a fan of
other cardgames or roguelike deck builders,
this is going to be a deck with a sweet aesthetic
and a lot of fun synergies for them to chew on.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to
my supporters for helping me to do
what I do here. If you want to join them in
supporting me, you can click the join button,
or follow the link to my patreon down in
the description. You’ll be getting access
to a back catalogue of bonus videos I’ve
made, and you may get the chance to have
your deck reviewed by me in one of my
quarterly deck reviews. Alright, bye.